hey everybody
move your retrospective time and once
again here's the one that got voted for
the most this one was actually the clear
winner
it wasn't close this week uh this is
lucio fulchi's
zombie i tell you what i never seen this
movie i know
it's the first time i've seen it but i
remember that poster back in the 80s
when i was a kid
what the hell oh no
stepping over the [ __ ] i remember seeing
that poster
when i was a kid back in the 80s going
[ __ ] that
[ __ ] that movie yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ]
that's just too hardcore for me
and it was in a time when it was like
the beginning of vhs rentals
and you couldn't find that one anyway
you never really saw it it was kind of
hard it's
kind of hard to get so i kind of had
imagined it to be a lot worse
than it really was but when i saw it you
know what i mean it was
still a good movie yeah but it was like
in terms of gore and everything just on
par with like david did
really yeah i thought the girl was
really good yeah it was good yeah well
that's kind of what this movie is famous
for it's like oh [ __ ] i should have worn
i have like actually a zombie shirt that
says we're gonna eat you with that
zombie on it that zombie is like iconic
and like i said
i mean the [ __ ] the poster for this
like i used to have
i think i gave it to my ex-husband for
christmas or his birthday or something
like that one year like many many years
ago
they used to make i don't know if they
still do but they used to make like a
really nice
mask of that zombie and it looks
amazing they used a lot of live worms in
this movie oh yeah
on the zombies which that helped oh the
italians they're just like what
you know it's cheaper we'll just dig up
some worms or some maggots or whatever
and throw that [ __ ] on there put in your
mouth it's fine
the effects look pretty good the masks
look pretty good i must say that
the photograph of the mask on the poster
looks better than it does in actual film
but it still looks good yeah this looks
pretty good like i said
and um this was supposed to be a movie
in the same universe as night of living
dead and day of the dead
kind of i'll get into that in italy it
was supposed to be kind of like a
license
it wasn't supposed to be kind of like a
licensed sort of
but that was done like after after the
fact
yeah because okay so the reason why now
in the u.s and in some other markets
it's just called zombie
and that's it in other parts of the
world it has like many other titles i've
seen it called
zombie flesh eaters i've seen it called
nightmare island
um it's probably most broadly known as
zombie 2
the zombie without an e on it now the
reason for that
is that george romero's dawn of the dead
was actually released in italy before it
came out in the u.s
but the version that they saw was just
called zombie
and it was actually re-edited from the
american version by
dario argento so he actually put a new
score in it uh using goblin like he
usually did
and um he made it kind of more like
action-packed i guess like he kind of
shuffled some of the scenes around and
cut some of the humor out and stuff
so the version that the italians saw of
donna the dead was just called zombie
and it was different than the one we got
so
what happened was the screenwriter of
this dardano society who
worked with lucio fulchi on a lot of
movies i'll kind of get into that later
on too
but he was writing a script in
i guess summer of 1978 and it was
actually not supposed to have anything
to do with dawn of the dead he wanted to
do like um a retro
voodoo zombie movie and originally the
screenplay was called nightmare island
or island of the living dead or
something like that
so when dawn of the dead like did so
well in italy
they were like well why don't we just
like say that it's
zombie two and then it's like a sequel
to dawn of the dead
that's what they did even though it's
really nothing to do
with dawn of the dead i mean the the
zombies are not
formed by the same process the zombies
do not look the same it's not set inside
them all there's no humor
it's basically like a caribbean old
style zombie movie i mean when did
darjano sachetti wanted something that
was like the old 30s like i walked with
a zombie and like those kind of movies
where it was more voodoo based
um whereas romero zombies were more even
though they don't really tell you what
romero zombies were
reanimated by like that [ __ ] from space
or whatever so that was like a different
thing it was more
scientific that wasn't really my
interpretation of the movie maybe i
missed something
i thought that the guy was didn't know
for sure they left it and they were
ambiguous why
the zombies happened right but they
implied that it was like more of a
voodoo
curse type of thing yeah i guess i guess
yeah
it's hard to decipher what italians mean
by their dialogue i mean i'm sorry
well it's all dubbed also yes just like
most italian movies from this
it's all dubbed and there's going to be
contradictions in the story so
and the way of one person
i think each character in the story has
their own take
on what the deal is yeah and they just
say what they think it is it doesn't
necessarily mean that that's what it
really is
because he was going i'm a rational man
of science this
can't be voodoo that's doing this it
must be something else
you know that he goes but i've looked at
it
from a a bacteriological way of viral
virality
i can't figure out what it is so maybe
it is kind of
you know maybe it is voodoo i don't know
you know it was that because it seemed
like the islanders were kind of like
yeah it's voodoo
but but there's a problem with that
hypothesis
all right there's a problem with that
hypothesis
and i don't want to spoil the end but
the ending well we have this movie's
vision
oh yeah they leave the damn they leave
the
the the island and all the [ __ ] new
york and entire united states and [ __ ]
evidently is
is is infected by it and i just didn't
think it's not the same process you know
and it was because a zombie got out yeah
you know that was like a bookend
it was some kind of an infection you
didn't have a book or
[ __ ] doing magical rituals to turn a
person into a zombie oh yeah it was a
plague
yeah but it was a plague of some sort
but it could have started out
as maybe like a voodoo it could have
been [ __ ]
i'm not it could have started making
sense out of a damn zombie movie well
yeah that's just not going to trigger
i'm just saying that like even though it
was like
perceived as like a rip-off of donna's
head or a or an unofficial sequel of
dawn of the dead
no it doesn't have anything to do with
dawn and the dead but i've seen all the
romero ones
and yeah they're trying that you're
they're trying to stuff that in there
yeah it can kind of go in there in terms
of quality
and now the writing isn't quite the same
the tone of the tone of it isn't quite
the same
like there's a lot more suspense um
well they're gonna you know the italians
are gonna call it suspense i'm gonna
call it waste of time
because it's like when it's taken to get
to the zombie island
but in true italian fashion they're
gonna show you a bunch of nudity which
of course i'm
you know that's gonna be great yeah you
got some girl
in on contract to [ __ ] just show it
all
you know in the damn diving scene and
her whole purpose in the movie is to
keep you entertained until the zombies
show up
and she's she's got that real typical
very popular aquiline kind of aquiline
athletic build that was real popular in
the early 80s this is before badonkadonk
so don't don't be you know don't
don't you know be waiting on some south
american level
[ __ ] epic proportions you know like
from brazil that's not what the deal is
this was
this was popular in the united states in
italy and in
and in new wave videos yeah you noticed
that that was the girl that should have
been popping new wavy can i just say
that like i saw a cinema snobs like
review of this
and yeah and he called that lady uh-huh
adrian barfro
okay yeah terrible perm
but that's the way the 80s were she was
pretty though yeah she was she was good
like
she just had a terrible problem and then
mia farrow's sister who looks just like
me
she's a pharaoh yeah yeah she was in a
lot of these kind of [ __ ]
she was in like what what was that
[ __ ] movie about the anthropophagis
or whatever that was about that cannibal
movie i think she would be doing that
too
i was waiting for it what's her name tia
tisa t says her name yeah t.i.s like
lisa but with yeah
so they were making up names even back
then all right they were but uh
i was waiting for her to bust it out but
she never got naked well she was
probably like the biggest star in there
well i know
not really because i guess like the guys
that were in this like the guy that
played uh the doctor and the guy
she didn't have much figure probably
anyway though she probably just real
skinny because her sister was pretty
skinny
that's true yeah they and they look like
that was real yeah and that was real
popular back then to [ __ ] just be
just
the 70s man i don't even it must have
been all the cocaine
you know because holy [ __ ] i've seen
some of the chicks in the in the movies
and i was just like how did they even
get that do they eat holy
cocaine jesus christ yeah they just ate
cocaine
yeah i don't need food i have cocaine
and cigarettes
but yes so basically all right so the
story of zombie if you haven't seen it
and like i said it came out much earlier
in uh italy than it did it didn't
actually come out over here until 1980
and um
it was i don't know if it was cut over
here i think it was um it's not now like
now they have the uncut version
but uh in the uk big time you know this
was right during the video nasty
brouhaha with mary whitehouse and all
that kind of crap going on
and uh so i think about two minutes was
cut out of this like all the worst gore
like the famous eye gouging
like some of the other stuff and they
shouldn't shouldn't cut that out well
yeah well
they put it back in in the in the 2000s
you could obviously okay look
these kind of [ __ ] gore effects they
would have affected me as a kid
especially on vhs
because the definition is very low and
especially on a crt tv that we had back
then
these effects would have been very
convincing you see them in hd
it's obvious that it's fake but it's
still the quality is still pretty good
and i think the effects in this look
really good like i said a lot of full
cheese movies
you know they really went all in like
with the gore and they wanted to be as
realistic as possible
so i mean the gore in this is a lot more
realistic than the gore and dawn of the
dead that's for sure
because the blood in that is like super
bright red it had a killer reputation
when i was a kid then everybody was
telling me oh no that one's even worse
and this one's even worse i was scared
to see the movie
but i probably would have watched it had
i found it i did kind of keep an eye out
for it yeah but i never did see it like
i said it was hard to get ahold of
i had it up on on a plateau on a
platform you know what i mean like oh
that [ __ ] must be like watching
a snuff film yeah
yeah well i thought it was going to be
like one of those cannibal movies
that were they were really killing those
animals i'm i hadn't seen anyone i
didn't have never seen it i showed him a
cannibal holocaust she showed me
cannibal hodges tonight i checked out i
was like nope
as soon as that dude shoved that damn
spike through that
through that damn possum or whatever it
was yeah
it's kawatamundi yeah it was a quad
money and then [ __ ] protesting and
i'm going now
no no you didn't even see the turtle i'm
a hunter i killed all kinds of animals
it's just i don't believe in killing
animals just to put them in a movie
torture
yeah well they i mean they have a
version without the animal cruelty but
with all the other [ __ ] in there
but um you know what i mean that movie
has like a horrible like reputation
because even like the
the people that got killed in that that
was so realistic that
the filmmakers got brought in on because
they thought that the people really got
killed
snuff movie charges i know he's trying
to make a another in that movie he was
trying to make a statement
yeah but you just don't do that with
real animals just for the amusement of
people
just yeah that's [ __ ] up no not at all
unacceptable yeah you only kill animals
for food and you try to make that [ __ ]
as quick as possible that was torturing
animals
cutting monkeys heads off and [ __ ] while
they were alive and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and that wasn't even a monkey
that was a that was was that a monkey or
was that a there wasn't a monkey
it was it was a monkey yeah yeah that
thing's protesting cut the top of his
head off no you don't play down on a
plated [ __ ] yeah
so uh but like i said the italians yeah
that's how they
they needed to go to jail for that if
you ask me yeah yeah but um yeah so this
this does not have real animal cruelty
in it right although you
questioned that shark i did actually now
what the weird thing about the shark
scene
didn't have teeth i don't think that was
a wild shark yes no it wasn't
well because what happened was so yeah
so that scene was actually
i don't know if it was written to the
script but fulchi was just like you know
he didn't really want to do that scene
but i guess that
somebody like one of the producers or
something was like hey we shot this
scene with like a shark trainer
like you know done up like a zombie and
he's like looks like he's wrestling the
shark what she did for real
um and and phil she was like man that's
stupid i don't want to put the
zombie fight in a shark in a movie but
once he saw the scene he's like oh all
right
and then he ended up putting it together
and that's like one of the most famous
scenes from that
this is very this is still what mid 80s
or early 80s early 8 years
no late 70s late 70s okay perfect
perfect i know why they did it it's on
the back of jaws
jaws was a huge phenomenon and you had
to see what would it be like if jaws and
a [ __ ] zombie
fought but it wasn't a very violent
scene it's just a guy kind of pretending
like he's wrestling with sharks swimming
around
the only thing that was unusual about it
was uh he's pretending like he's biting
the shark
the shark i noticed didn't have any
teeth and i don't know or it didn't look
like her
look what kind of shark was that it
looked like a lemon shark i want to say
but i'm not real sure i used to be real
up on my leg i was watching the shark
and
he was grabbing that shark and it was
definitely not a wild shark it was used
to be an animal jerk didn't care
no well yeah he's just like sharks like
even the lady freaking out when it was
like yeah
he's like she's fine i'm not gonna eat
you
i'm just swimming i'm just swimming that
was a well-fed
pet shark well yeah like i said and that
zombie was actually a shark trainer
and that's like that whole thing was why
they put that in the movie to start with
because that was i don't think that was
initially in the story but yeah so what
happens in this movie is that
at the beginning basically there's this
derelict
uh sailboat that's in new york harbor so
these cops go and find it they don't
find anybody on there and they're just
like what the [ __ ] and then all of a
sudden like this big fat zombie like
comes out and bites one of the cops
and then there's like a little bit it's
kind of like the the opening of some
some stories of of [ __ ] dracula when
dracula's ship comes up
that's what i thought it was like a
plague ship and it does end up being
that yeah that's what it was
so so then you kind of go into like this
little bit of an investigative thing
where teas of pharaoh's character um
it was her dad's boat so the police are
like investigating like you know what
happened to your dad where the [ __ ] was
he and all this other kind of stuff
so her and this friend of hers um who is
like a newspaper reporter they're gonna
go to the island that her dad was
supposedly
you know on called matul in the
caribbean
and they're gonna go check out what
happened also um
in the new york portion of the movie the
guy that's telling the newspaper
reporter
like you know you need to go check out
the story or whatever that is a cameo by
lucio folgi
and uh obviously he didn't speak a word
of english so
you can really tell that he's like
speaking italian it's like dubbed over
well because i feel like a lot of the
actors in this like ian mcculloch um
yeah al cliver i think they were british
um and olga carlotto's uh the woman who
got her eye gouged out i believe
she was german although i think she was
speaking english in this it looked like
but like i said a lot of italian movies
i pretty much all italian movies from
this time period were always just like
everyone was dubbed over because
all the actors were from different
places and they just all spoke their own
language and then they just dubbed it
and the movie had nine different dubs
that they played all over the world so
the movies could play everywhere
it was a good it was a good scheme to
make money if you were italian well it
seems
like the most efficient way of doing it
you know what i mean like the cheapest
way i guess and the european markets
were real
forgiving about dubbing u.s wasn't
uh now in the horror scene they're a
little more tolerant of it because the
horror scene they were just happy to get
a horror movie
from somewhere somewhere you know and
actually if it looked good this was a
good movie
and italy kind of had the reputation of
like not only having
a bunch more knockers in it but also
like having
really good gore yeah so i feel like it
you know [ __ ] was harder to get hold of
back then they did do a vhs release i
think in the us in 81
i want to say but it was the cut version
i don't think they even released this
uncut
in the u.s until the 90s yeah you know
what i mean like they had
as far as i'm aware i had the anchor bay
one
but um i don't know what happened to it
i remember back in the day you know if
you got your hands on any kind of
italian horror movie or italian movie
we kind of considered it it was like a
couple steps above getting
getting your hands on a [ __ ] soft car
porn flick when you're a kid yeah
because the europeans you were good
i could see some [ __ ] yeah they were
just like all they did not care about
like the tits or the bush or anything
they would just put it in there
and they they understood the market yeah
that's what teenage boys wanted to see
it's true well yeah they knew exactly
what teenage boys wanted to see
there's like they said yeah they didn't
give a [ __ ] about any of these ratings
or anything
they knew that it would eventually end
up on some kind of vhs market around
this time that it was coming out
yeah and it did and movies like this
played for or
were available for a long time on vhs
afterwards you get it now
yeah so i don't know if they're still
making money on it it's probably been
sold several times
i think just recently because i was
watching a video by adam caesar he was
an author and he also has like a horror
channel over there if you want to check
him out
but um he just got i think it was just
from last year
where they did like a really nice like
4k remaster of this movie and that came
out on blu-ray with like all the
it had like a disc of the score uh by
fabio fritzi
and all this other stuff and it looked
like really nice and actually if this
movie's on shutter right now if you want
to watch it
if you haven't seen it but it this is a
nice looking movie i feel like
italians and particularly folci because
he had a reputation for gore films which
is kind of all he's known for in the us
even though he made like movies in every
single genre but i feel like
that they kind of get a reputation of
being like
shitty looking or being like not cheaply
produced or anything like that but this
is a nice looking
movie i mean the shots are framed really
nice it's like it's got a really good
horror new wave score yeah that's
something you see on a nuke
yeah it was like a new like i said fabio
fritzi did like
most of folgi's movies i believe so
it could stand it could it could go
right along with a romero flick
it has problems that italian movies
always have
weird editing and pacing weird dialogue
choices
uh weird choices and showing scenes of
you know like guys slapping women
and they love their men's life over the
top [ __ ]
every i think every single dialogue i've
ever seen
but that's just the way the italians
were and that's that's what they were
going to put in the movie and that's
that's that's the formula that worked
for them in their market
and it was good enough to sell um to
other markets
you see during the time when all this
[ __ ] was coming out
it was sounds strange to say so but
italy's economy was [ __ ] up the
average person in italy didn't have a
television
they went to the movie theaters they
didn't pay much to see these movies
maybe maybe a quarter but they saw a lot
of them
there were movie houses all over italy
and they were constantly packed
and evidently they weren't real strict
about ratings or how old people were so
there were kids watching these
yeah and they made a [ __ ] ton of movies
and you know you had a director making
eight nine movies at one time almost
kind of like hong kong theater
so that's where this kind of stuff comes
from you had good italian directors and
you had
shitty italian directors and it was
because
italy had a a vast market for [ __ ]
cheap movies they had to constantly play
in the theaters well yeah i mean they
were getting movies from the us
and from other parts of europe but then
like the you know the appetite for
movies was so insatiable that it's like
they had all these directors that would
just make like knockoffs
yeah of you know it's like oh jaws was a
big hit let's make the last shark let's
make
devil fish let's oh you like you like
superman
all right we'll give you some more of
that uh hold on come up with some [ __ ]
jaguar man
no it was puma puma man that was that's
right well they came up with [ __ ]
men i want to say it wasn't as bad as
turkey
turkey come up with some [ __ ] crazy
[ __ ] and this is this
the turkish movies are hilarious in
their own right but it's like
those look like they were made for like
a buck 98. you'd go to jail
if you made that movie here in the
united states you'd go to jail i mean
the best one was i think
was it turkish batman where they had a
scene with batman and robin going to the
strip club
yeah and then they would [ __ ] they'd
grab having sex with puppets or kissing
when they're a weird puppet scene in
there and i was sitting there going what
the [ __ ] and then crafting
scenes from [ __ ] star wars yeah we're
[ __ ] soundtracked by
journey shameless yeah soundtrack by
journey
[ __ ] and they just it's so fun though
yeah and then you got spiderman and
spiderman's a serial killer
and he had a green with a green
i think it was supposed to be blue but i
think the color processing was so bad it
looked great
either that or they were just like well
that's as close as we could get they're
like whatever
close enough so you're not talking about
at that level i mean they had some
they had some master directors you know
[ __ ] especially they had a couple of
them in the damn
westerns that were really good but you
know
it's it has problems that an italian
movie has
but those those problems are only from
the american point of view for the
from from the italian point of view that
[ __ ] was awesome and like i said i
i mean i love italian movies so i'm like
very willing like especially any kind of
gel or movies or anything like that i'm
into it so it's like i really like that
um i really like that whole aesthetic so
that kind of [ __ ] doesn't bother me i
can see how
i mean this movie is very gory and it
has like some really iconic
like gore shots especially like you know
the eye gouging like the [ __ ]
uh all the zombies like coming out of
the earth with the worms and everything
uh olga carlotto's getting eaten by
zombies it's like it's you know it's
very like realistic and [ __ ] like that
but there is a lot of this almost you
know what
i know this is kind of a weird thing to
say but it almost kind of reminds me the
pacing of it reminds me a little bit of
serpent and the rainbow
where it's just kind of like because
like i said you have this you know
opening sequence that's set in new york
city which they did actually shoot there
um and then so it takes a while for them
to get to the island and then once they
get to the island which i think they
shot in uh the dominican republic
somewhere
um once they get to the island it takes
a while for like the zombies to like
invade
but it's so it's not the kind of thing
where
i guess nowadays when they make a zombie
movie it's like you know it has to be
like zombies like immediately
and like zombies like through the whole
thing whereas this one has like
much more build up of like the mystery
like where did this
girl's dad go it's like what's going on
on this island what's this doctor up to
does he have something to do with making
the zombies like inadvertently or
inadvertently
if you ask me i think that's a strange
decision for them to do because they
i could understand it if there was a
limited budget
and you wanted like a long build up and
then a big payoff
in the last 15 or 20 minutes you know
what i mean i can understand that
the thing is though is that the build up
to the zombie island is not a cheap
buildup
they're in new york they're doing [ __ ]
on in in above yeah they shot a lot in
there
and [ __ ] underwater shot there so it's
not cheap footage
i i really had it been my movie i'd have
done a romero style
and right from the beginning there had
been a zombie outbreak on the island and
a lot of zombie action through the whole
thing that probably would have been
cheaper
and more bang for the buck maybe so
cause it doesn't cost much to dress
somebody up as a zombie and then just
shoot them on location walking around
although i feel like the zombies in this
one looked a lot better because
you know as much as i love romero's
movies i feel like
most of the background extra zombies in
like dawn of the dead for example
were just like people with like blue
green makeup on that's kind of
that's that's what some of them were in
this i mean okay look as soon as the
zombie outbreak
really starts rolling on the island this
is this is
as good if not better than a than a
romero flick well i always liked
i always liked the voodoo thing of it i
was i like voodoo zombie movies and i
feel like there's not
a lot of those yeah there's no such
thing as made just the quan
the quality of the [ __ ] the way the
zombies look yeah and and and
the scariness of it yeah and what
they're doing
i think there was payoff in the movie it
wasn't quite
long enough that i i would have i would
have saved money with all the [ __ ]
new york shots and all the
shark shots and underwater titties and
[ __ ]
tight ass i don't know i don't want them
taking that's all right i love the shark
that's all great that was all she
i i think i think i'd just rather have a
bunch of zombies
another half hour like you could have
just started it on the island and i
started it pretty much on the island but
the thing that i liked about the new
york thing though at the beginning did
explain it is that it
ended at the end because at the
beginning like that one zombie like
falls in the water like in the new york
harbor
and then they go to the island and that
all that [ __ ] happens and then at the
end
like the two like teas of pharaoh and
the other dude like escape the island
and they're like hey we to bring this
guy back so
we can prove like what happened and then
when they get back to new york spoiler
alert
zombies have already invaded because of
the cop because the cop got zombified
they got attacked by the
zombie like yeah the whole going to the
island and from new york to the island
almost kind of felt like they were doing
the king kong thing where they're going
to
skull island it was kind of like i think
you tried to do that
yeah okay you could do that but i think
i would have cut i would have cut the
i would have cut it way down just for a
few because it was like it was too long
i built that coming from but um
once the zombies started to happen it
did feel like
as good or better as a as a romero i
mean i love those shots of the zombies
coming out of the ground yeah i think
that looks so cool because i really
really like
like i said i like the serious tone of
it i like the i like all the worms i
love that kind of [ __ ] it's like
i kind of disagree with the with the
voodoo
element i he was talking like it was
voodoo yeah
i don't think he from what i've got from
the dialogue he wasn't sure
i don't think it well like i said they
didn't say definitively that voodoo had
caused it or maybe he caused her maybe
it was a disease or something
like that looked like a just to me
mike's from what my understanding was
it was a normal romero style zombie i
think it was a disease
i don't think it came i don't know if it
came from outer space or anything like
that the thing is
in night of living dead you know they
said that they thought it came from this
contaminated
or some [ __ ] like that but it's not
definitive even
in that movie they thought that me yeah
they're like oh maybe that mean it is
because that's something that happened
so that wasn't that
either it was just something yeah
which like you said it can be this it's
you know but the island natives like
said that it was voodoo because people
were coming to life in the morgues
yeah you know yeah coming up out of the
ground
every now and then you know so it just
reanimated the dead but there was never
a definitive explanation
of why right except me but like i said
this
i i guess because this has like a
caribbean island setting so it just has
like more of a voodoo flavor to it yeah
then yeah then dawn of the dead which is
definitely a consumerist
type yeah well because they had like the
background music and everything like
that because i don't think that's what
it was
i don't think it had anything to do with
voodoo though yeah i think they thought
it did
yeah that's what i'm saying that's right
you know first it seemed like it was a
disease
because i think the doctor dr menard
that was there i think he was like
working on
why it was happening and he didn't
really know because he was like
he was going down the same path as
romero yeah yeah
he's coming with ideas but they weren't
sure why now when you talk about later
on in the walking dead they didn't know
why it was like some kind of virus there
it was a virus that they always had
yeah yeah but um yeah so as far as i can
remember please correct me if i'm wrong
but i'm pretty sure that this was lucio
fulchi's first
like straight up horror gore movie
because prior to this one like i said he
had made westerns he'd made comedies
he'd made like all different kinds of
things
now he had made a couple of giallo
movies uh he made don't
don't torture a duckling which i think
is also on shutter if you want to watch
that too i haven't seen it a long time
didn't anything torture in ducklings
don't touch her duckling yet
um and also he made uh the psychic
better known as setenote and nero or
murder to the tune of seven black notes
which actually we need to do a review on
that because that is
weirdly like probably one of my favorite
lucio folgi movies and i feel like it
doesn't get talked about enough
it's just it's so awesome and it was
written by the same guy that wrote this
movie
so when this movie came out it was like
massively successful
all over the world i think it cost 410
million lira to make which is apparently
not that much money i don't know how
much it is in today's dollars
but it made like over like 30 billion
lira like all over the world or
something and it's still like a cult
classic today
so i guess on the strength of that lucio
fulchi kind of went off
and did you know his kind of iconic gore
films like you know the beyond city the
living dead
um you know house by the cemetery like
all his other
his kind of trilogy of undead type
movies
so this was kind of like the you know
the genesis of that of him kind of going
in that direction for a little while
um there apparently were some sequels to
this uh there was a zombie
three which i think lucio fulchu was
working on but then he got sick
and so they passed it on to someone else
um and i believe there was also a zombie
four
now i haven't seen either of those so
i'm not sure
if they're any good or not like i kind
of get the impression that they're
probably not that good because you know
what i'm hearing about no one really
talks about them
like i saw cinema snob like reviewed
zombie three but i didn't have time to
watch it like to see if
it was any good or not i just assumed
that it was just like another
cheap like knockoff but i don't know if
anyone's seen it and like would
recommend that i watch it then let me
know because i will watch it what'd you
think this one
i liked it i mean like i said the pacing
is a little slow in the beginning
but yeah i mean i don't know i kind of
like the gimmicky like
you know iconic scenes and stuff like
that like it's kind of fun yeah
yeah i see i see what people liked it
back yeah today like i can see why
they've been
yeah back in the day it would have it
would have had a lot more impact yeah
we kind of were used to a little bit
slower edits into the movies so
they didn't seem quite that slow well
yeah because that's kind of like what
most movies in the 70s were paced like
yeah
particularly even gore movies even like
really iconic like gore movies that have
like
a few scenes in them if you watch them
now like wit
you know with the attention span of
people nowadays they seem very slow like
even slasher movies
like i was watching some slasher movies
you know that i hadn't seen since i was
a kid and i'm like wow like a whole lot
of nothing happens in this movie and
then like
every you know every 20 minutes somebody
gets like a machete or something but it
makes sense because
back in those days you didn't have a lot
of opportunities to see
imagery you saw posters you saw pictures
you saw television and you went to go
see movies it was a big deal imagery was
a [ __ ] big deal
nowadays you carry imagery with you
around on your phone yeah
well everyone's seen all this massive
[ __ ] massively good
cg type imageries and these scenes and
[ __ ] so we weren't
inundated with [ __ ] high quality
imagery all the time
it's video games we're just blocked
because everybody's seen everything
you know what i mean yeah so you can't
really the age of imagery is over
i mean and like i said even as cool as a
lot of the gore is in this like
i especially like i'm a big fan of the
scene where he picks up that like metal
cross and like takes the top of that
zombie's head off and then all the goop
comes out like i don't know
you were talking about diablo movies was
alice sweet alice a giallo movie really
it was like um giallo adjacent okay that
was my favorite one actually because i'm
not even sure that was a tower it's not
it's not italian does it felt italian it
was kind of like
you know a different country's
interpretation of a jail i don't even
know
i guess it sort of is but it's not it
doesn't have
no we did a review of it a while back
uh very very young brook shields was in
it yeah
but um yeah it's super cool it's a girl
killing people okay yeah that's what you
think and then you find out it's not
yeah yeah spoiler one no i'm just saying
that the movie is like super old
yeah i don't worry about moved like hey
creepy dudes trying to creep out on
these little 15 year old girls
oh yeah that's a big factor trying to
screw them and [ __ ]
that's you i just thought of that jar of
cockroaches and cockroaches and throwing
matches in it and [ __ ] yeah and you know
there's just that was an era where you
could [ __ ] do creepy [ __ ] with
[ __ ] kids and get away with it
that's true on in the film yeah yeah
yeah
yeah weird [ __ ] i mean like i said i
guess technically you could probably
call that a yellow movie although it
doesn't really have like a lot of the
hallmarks of the kind of classic italian
ones i suppose
but it's kind of like like i said it's
another country's take on it so
and i've seen it called the jello like
other yeah and the other was like an
american version of the
jet of the jalikana the one with the
twins the twins yeah that was creepy
no no that wasn't that wasn't anything
like that it just kind of reminded it
was being played at the same time
i mean a jealous movie is basically a
baby in the damn pickle jar and killed
it oh that used to freak me out
seeing the top of the baby's head like
was it a pickle jar or was it it was
like a cast
it was a cask of [ __ ] like a whiskey
wouldn't it or something like that or
wine or water i can't believe it's
looking for the baby they couldn't find
it the book was good too yeah by thomas
tryon he also read harvest homes just a
little kid
little evil kid he was psychic it it's
kind of like something
kind of like a kind of like damien or
something yeah i mean
well like i said jello movies generally
don't have supernatural elements
although the folcy when the psychic did
but it was still like structured but
like they don't usually have
supernatural elements
it's usually like a crime story
not quite like a police procedural
because it focuses more on the victim
but it's usually like a masked killer
that's going around
so alice sweet alice is kind of like
that because it's a killer with a mask
that's going around picking people off
so it is kind of like that um but i i
would not call it it's an american movie
wasn't it
i think it was american yeah it felt
italian though
the way it was filmed well because it
was influenced by that yeah i mean and
that's what we were talking about we
were talking about this a little bit
last night because we were talking
about how like i said i think some
people that don't know a lot about
horror movies will have the perception
that
italians just made like rip-offs of
american
horror movies but that's really not the
case yeah americans are ripping off the
jet yeah
the other way around yeah and in a lot
of ways it kind of is the other way
around because i mean you can say
like for example like slasher movies
which obviously were influenced by jello
movies
um but also i would call the first
slasher movie
um bay of blood or twitch of the death
nerve which was mario baba
that was the first movie that had like a
pov
killer uh a first one that was going
around like killing
you know a bunch of victims like one by
one like in a very slasher movie fashion
and that came out in like 1968 1969
something like that so even before black
christmas
um which was 1974 but i would probably
call that the first slasher maybe yeah
you know early john carpenter he was
kind of ripping off a lot of [ __ ]
italian type aspects oh yeah big time
you know escape from new york some a lot
of the lighting and stuff in there with
the
italian style it's very jealous yeah
because they had that really bright
saturated right kind of color all right
so that'll do it for our review of
luccio fulche zombie who
hope you guys enjoyed it and we will see
you on the next one bye